think like life is about choices and
consequences and i i do think there's a
sector of guys that probably would cheat
if they felt like there was no
consequence but just like it's like
imagining two though yeah imagine if the
guy is suddenly finds himself in a room
with like a you know victoria's secret
model or something and there's there's
going to be no consequence to this
nobody's ever going to find out it's
going to be completely right would he do
it probably in many cases yes so but
there's a group of guys that would say
don't put me in that room because i
don't want to be tempted to do that yes
but guys
sorry go ahead
this person you're talking about is a
decimal point outlier yeah and more than
likely if you take a group of men that
wouldn't do it and you pull religion and
guilt out then tell me what the number
of men would be now we're like three
decimals oh i'm sure i'm sure religion
and guilt is part of it but that's like
part of society like that like like if
if you made and in this case like this
isn't a situation where they're open and
honest with the woman like i think
cheating is wrong if you're not open and
honest with her that makes it cheating
yeah yeah and so and so what i'm saying
is like
i think there's a group of guys that
don't necessarily like partake in that
because they they don't want the
consequence that comes with it yeah
loyalty that's different that's not
loyalty what is it it's it's
fear of consequences yeah it's just fear
of consequences they still want to do it
they would still do it if they knew they
wouldn't get caught and they did already
doing it in their head to do something
and not do it yeah like they should like
that's like no it would be because
that's like me saying okay i meet the
i'm with a guy and i meet a higher
status guy that i'd rather sleep with
like
that's like me saying oh um there's no
loyalty like
sorry i'm trying to formulate this right
i i would still want to sleep with that
guy but because i love the person i'm
with like you choose not to you choose
not to put yourself in situations where
you're going to be tempted like that's
that's part of just being a human is
making choices well i mean
it kind of cuts both ways because there
are people in the sort of the men's
manosphere space who would believe that
actually all women would cheat if they
have the opportunity because they
believe hypergamy is so strong
that um as soon as a woman walks into a
room with a i think all women are
tempted to cheat on someone
but i think again you make you make
choices based on you know your loyalty
to that guy like there's always going to
be a better guy always you know you know
what what i think we're missing here is
you say that
but just like we were talking about
earlier when there's a dissonance you
won't sleep with a man that's a certain
level because you don't believe he's
doing anything but sleeping with you
most women will jump if they think they
can land on that branch
and what they do is start creating
stories about how how their current guy
is not doing some [ __ ] but really
it's hypergamy in action
oh he plays video game or he's not doing
this or this or there's some stupid [ __ ]
because if she thinks she can actually
land that guy and he won't just pump and
dump her she'll start talking [ __ ] about
the other guy and i'm gonna tell you
right now because i get this [ __ ] a lot
when women start they'll they'll send a
facebook message or something and start
talking [ __ ] about their husband i'm
like the [ __ ] she's trying to jump
you know but at
it's
this
monkey branch yeah but at the same time
you can also not have social media like
if that's something you're going to be
as a girl if you're going to be tempted
to do that and you made that choice you
made that lifelong commitment you cannot
have social media and like you're going
to be a lot less tempted to do that type
of thing right or you could get a man
that keeps her frame and uh you could
have social media and he could be in the
inboxes
yeah i mean you could do that too
what
yeah so
if if i'm with a girl i have her
instagram i can see it when she gets a
message
oh what wow yeah what what did she see
yours what's wrong with that no
to be honest i'm thinking about it and i
am i was just like what was you actually
mentioning but definitely between me and
my husband yeah but yeah all laptops all
phones are right open but if i was just
like somebody a banking campaign so why
wouldn't instagram try we've been
together a very long time if i was just
dating somebody or even if i'm boyfriend
and girlfriend with them
no
are you having access to my things can i
have access to yours though it doesn't
go by first so it's only a one-way
street come on that's ridiculous no is
it
yeah girls agree with that
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely
because because they've they've quit
they've quit looking
oh because you've been honest like i am
gonna do what i'm gonna do finger no
cause i'm her best option
yeah but she knows i you are going to do
what you're going to do yeah right but
yeah there's zero lying okay okay
that's fine
genuinely happy yes
happier do you have your questions okay
that's enough absolutely i care i think
you should absolutely love the [ __ ] out
of your girl you should treat her better
than anyone we've ever treated that's
what he means he says queens versus yeah
i mean i get it and the only reason we
call him the only reason you call hoe is
because i personally think if you call
all the other women hoes it makes your
girl feel better and as a man your job
is to paint a reality yeah yeah for her
if you really love her you need to paint
a reality
are you guys coming around you're coming
out to the whole terminology
[Laughter]
i know it's a lot but if i really really
love her
i want to paint a reality that makes her
life a dream
because otherwise because she can deal
with the truth but otherwise she's
sitting at home like this
young lady saying oh i think why don't
she just listen know that
my man's a [ __ ] women are trying to get
at him but he'll never leave me these
dumb hoes think they're gonna steal my
man it'll never happen and there's a
point there's a piece in that it just
really clearly just woman and not the
man that's that i have an issue with
that as well so what was that
said it's put in the the that's because
the behavior sorry i've got quite a few
voices um put in uh the behavior on the
woman and not the man like if you you're
labeling like these hoes like they're
coming at me but actu actually is the
man that's actively going out looking
for no no why he's in a relationship
sometimes i'm saying yes to it and
making the choice to actually do it but
it's talking about choices that's
exactly what it is
it's the hoes that are coming out like
yeah look at justin's okay
like
but it is it is that woman's choice to
allow him to penetrate her with his
penis i was just about to say but the
man is the one that's going in yeah so
even if the guy even if the door is open
if the woman is like i'm open to you
it's the man that has decided i am going
to leave my queen to enter into this
home what does that say about the dude
he's not going to leave her queen is he
no no i mean i'm leaving her side her
bedside i'm not going to sleep with her
tonight or this minute and i'm going to
go to this ho what does that say about
the man and his penis that he where is
the respect it says that he's a man like
every other man and his penis has no
worth
no no
because well biologically the penis
really doesn't have much worth the
vagina does because it creates life i i
agree that's uh that's that's
like the value of a man versus a woman
that's just really that's a biological
fact exactly right
but it just makes the point i made a
while ago that no woman has
that one quality that every man wants
which is a variety it is it's very very
hard for a lot of women to kind of
understand this and internalize it and
emotionally accept it but it's again as
amazing as you are
there's still going to be
you're still going to be tempted men are
still going to be tested by some others
but it's still about
choice got to remember you've got to
remember as well though the distinction
between
the sexual desire and the man and love
or whatever we want to call it you know
that deeper feeling that there is a
distinction yes it is this whole thing
absolutely yeah
absolutely i do think men and women
cheating is different like i think if a
woman cheats she's trying to leave you
if a man yes yes yes just like
it's like a handshake
and that's what i mean because again
yeah absolutely you can absolutely
sleep with a woman who you may find very
attractive and very sexy and everything
else but your heart is still completely
with another woman
before you sleep with that woman do you
tell them that you're in a relationship
[Laughter]
i've said this on other podcasts if you
lined up every man on the planet
and you took them and you put them in a
room and you said hey listen nobody's in
here it's just us you can hit this
button
and
you can
love your wife
be an amazing father
sleep with as many hoes as you want and
then go home and hold your wife or have
sex with your wife and hold her at night
all you have to do is hit this button
and everybody will be cool with that
every man would look left he'd look
right make sure nobody's in the room and
he hit the [ __ ] button i feel like
every woman would do exactly the same
thing no that's what we call i don't
know i don't think it would no no i
don't that's
thinking that women don't have exactly
the same thing it's the same level but
we aren't exactly the same but we're
yeah we're chemically different we're
biologically different like women
release a chemical during sex that men
don't
so like it's i think it's fat
oxytocin yeah so so we we equate sex to
love
no we don't
well it's just a lie well women have
desires in exactly the same way every
girl i know that's done that that like
like doesn't have that feeling anymore
it's because she slept with too many
dudes but early on
like dude she lost her virginity two
second guys she slept with like she was
very attached i agree with you but could
we not say the same for men could we not
say if you if you had if you had men and
they had only slept with two women they
may have that same chemical attachment
like i loved that woman and the more
vaginas that they went into the less
they valued it and that could be the
differences i do think at some level
like that does happen like i think if a
dude sleeps with say 100 girls 200 girls
like i i do think it impacts your
ability to bond not like you can't bond
in the same way
how dare you but
but i don't think but it's not if you
look at the numbers when you rate
marital happiness based on sexual
partners if a woman um has had sex with
more than five people her chance of a
happy marriage in ten years goes from
eighty percent as a virgin to twenty
five percent where men where men
no they survey people they they just ask
and who would like something so can i
finish
that so okay so the thing is and the
thing is with men it actually their
marital happiness increase it's the
highest as a virgin so i do i do think
that's the ideal but it increases like
their marital happiness increases at
like eight partners
so they're like more satisfied with
their wife
yeah yeah men are more happy so that
it's just more evidence that we're
biologically different
but yeah i don't think it's evidence i
just think there's like surveys and
stats just do you know everything what
do you guys think you guys are the the
women in the room that do you think i
mean not necessarily talk about you
personally but do you think conceivably
you you agree with this idea then that
if a woman could press this button and
she could sleep with as many guys as she
wanted but still go home to her husband
that she'd be up for that do you think
most women would like if you eliminate
like shame in society yeah like if
you've never been able to do that then
yes it's not gonna be as many
as men
because it's not going to be as many
it's going to be quality so you if you
could press a button and nobody would
know
there would be certain people that you
would be like i would absolutely sleep
with that guy here we go absolutely it's
not going to be the level of oh any any
hole is a goal it's not that this is
this is bingo but i think sorry
i was just going to say this is so sorry
what i was going to say really quickly
is that i think the the difference is
that the man you want to come home to
will change each time
but with us it's the same woman
because you're going to sleep like let's
look you just said a second ago right oh
he's amazing i definitely want the
chance to go sleep with him yeah and
then
oh but i gotta come back home to this
same schlub
who's letting me cheat on a bunch of
rules are the same no they're not the
same no no no i'm not saying the rules
are different i'm saying
men's and women's interpretations of
that are completely different
biologically i i hear what you're saying
i get so you're firmly fixed on this
whole idea that when a woman sleeps with
a man there's going to be this chemical
bond not necessarily no no but if but if
you find the dick size let's say let's
let's just use
let's just use comments that's actually
true that's totally true that's true but
let's just say for example like let's
just purely use numbers to make it easy
right let's say your husband is a five
yeah right just arbitrarily i know i
don't know who the man i'm just throwing
for the arbitrary sake let's say he's a
five right
and then this rule comes into place yeah
cool all right you meet a handsome
producer over here
right okay you're like all right bang
and then you have to come home to him
yeah there's a five
you're like okay cool and then the next
day you do the same thing again and the
next day do the same thing again the
next day the same thing again eventually
you're like i don't want to keep coming
home to this [ __ ] i want to come
home for that [ __ ] right and
you're saying that is very different
from men men don't feel that way totally
different
i can
that doesn't happen
well they do because
the reason they do though is because the
secretary is giving them something that
the wife isn't giving him
and
that is in the most in most cases in
most cases the secretary is giving him
peace
right
can i can i look for caveats okay i'm
just saying okay
also what you said is very important he
leaves to marry the secretary
so what he's going to do there
is he could sleep with a woman we'll
call her a lady
[Laughter]
every night yeah we're getting there
it's
dude i don't hate women at all i love
women um
but what you notice is that
he is now going to love that girl so if
if he leaves his wife which is probably
aged and all that other all those other
things if i'm being honest
and he's probably leaving her for a
woman that probably looks up to him if
it's their secretary he's in a power
position with her the other one expects
it because he's in the position the
other one's at the country club it
doesn't respect him the same way spends
money spends all his money nags not
happy and so he leaves and notice what
he does though he marries her guess what
he's still sleeping with ladies